- I woke up this morning,
and there’s no way
I could get back in this boat
and handle big gators.
I’m hurting too bad.
I’ll put him
on top of the ice chest.
[bleep]
He jacked on my knee.
My knee, man.
- You gonna be all right, T?
- My knee is hurting pretty bad.
It’s not gonna get any better
by going to do the same thing
I was doing yesterday,
loading big gators and stuff,
so we’re gonna try
something else.
My knee’s
pretty painful right now,
So they say he’s good,
so we’re gonna see.
A traiteur is a treater,
but they use prayers to treat.
Doctors use medicines,
they use prayers.
I believe in prayer, so, I mean,
I went to traiteurs
when I was younger.
It’s been a long time
since I went to one,
but I really believe in ’em.
My mom was one.
My mom would treat for warts.
So I believe in ’em.
I have no warts.
This is an ancient method
that I don’t know
how long it’s been going on.
And I’m gonna give this a shot.
- All right, T.
- My knee’s really
hurting me pretty bad.
I gotta try
to get something done.
I need to get back out there.
Daniel’s actually out there
today running lines by himself.
- Okay. Well, let’s go ahead
and get you treated
so we can get your healing
taking place.
I’m just gonna lay my hands
on your knee here
and say some prayers over it.
They’re really just
simple prayers to God
that was said
in our native French tongue.
[speaking French]
For me to be able
to offer a certain thing
that is dying out
in our culture,
it’s something that I feel
not only honored to do,
but it’s required of me.
[speaking French]
Amen. Thank God
for your healing.
You just gotta have faith
in the healing.
- I believe in prayers strongly.
- Mm-hmm.
- So I have faith
that it’s gonna work.
- All right. Come on out.
- Seeing Colby really put me
back on track, I think.
Ready to get back out there
and get the job done.
Give it a little time,
we’re gonna be back in action.